Okay,
everybody,
let's start in
today.
I want to talk about green building and,
uh,
the,
the opportunity to also think about the laws that surround green building,
uh,
and also the energy,
implications of green building standards.
And I'd like to also address the,
the,
uh,
the history by having you think about the way that these standards have evolved
over time,
uh,
particularly the evolution of certification programs.
So the idea of certification,
uh,
I want you to think about it quite broadly at the outset because it basically
implies that certain standards are being applied to something.
It might be a product,
it could be a service,
uh,
could be a,
a neighborhood,
a city,
so that,
uh,
the idea that,
there is an expert group that would a review,
uh,
something whether or not it's your academic preparation and performance or
whether or not it's a building's performance,
uh,
and then certify it and give it a symbol.
Uh,
it would,
uh,
rank it relative to others.
Uh,
that,
uh,
is one obvious example would be looking at a GPA and a transcript.
Well we'll see after today's lecture is that the green building programs that
have a walled in Europe,
in the United States and Australia,
they really are,
are based on that same kind of concept.
So how would you rate,
uh,
the environmental and health responsibility in energy efficiency of,
of new building standards?
Uh,
how would they apply or how might they apply to a renovation projects?
So I'm basically going to use the lecture today to share with you a,
an overview of a paper that will be published in about two weeks.
That is a critique of,
of the US Green Building Council's program,
uh,
known as lead.
So I'd like you also to think about,
uh,
the importance of the building sector in,
its demand for energy in the United States.
Buildings consume 76% of the u s uh,
electricity in the mid almost half of the nation's greenhouse gases.
So that how we manage the future of building and development will very much
influence the intensity of energy demand.
And keep in mind also that the u s consumes more energy than any other country
in the world.
Uh,
and US consumers consumes nearly 25% of the world's energy and only accounts for
5% of the world's population.
So that our energy demand is increasing at about 2% per year.
So why,
why might that be?
I mean,
obviously we're changing our behavior.
Uh,
we're changing our technology,
uh,
and our dependence on technology.
Uh,
and also the environments that,
uh,
we shape around us have enormous implications for energy that often are not well
understood,
uh,
for a variety of reasons.
Uh,
you,
for example,
probably have no understanding of,
of how your daily behavior,
uh,
and variability and your behavior might influence your daily energy demand.
Uh,
the way that you manage your computers,
the way that you manage your,
your windows,
your,
your air exchange between indoor and outdoor environments.
Will you manage lights,
whether or not you have a car on campus,
if you do,
how often you use it,
where do you park it?
Uh,
what's,
it's fuel efficient.
So thinking about how to keep track of,
of an individual's energy demand is,
is really not in most people's minds,
clearly defined.
So,
as I just said,
the contribution to the climate change problem,
uh,
and our,
our dependence on foreign oil,
uh,
is really,
very,
uh,
much dependent upon the way that we build and the way that we,
set up standards to encourage energy efficiency.
So 39% of co two emissions come from the building sector,
40% of energy,
uh,
consumption,
total energy consumption,
uh,
13% of water consumption and about 15% of the gross domestic product per year,
is associated with the building sector.
Think about the different patterns of growth and how the different patterns of
growth,
uh,
and neighborhood development influenced the way that we use energy.
Uh,
these houses are not connected,
so they can't gain any benefit for,
for,
uh,
heat,
conservation,
uh,
by having a joining walls.
Uh,
they all had their own yards.
And in fact,
if you think about how people move around in these kinds of neighborhoods,
uh,
you'd realize that,
because of the fencing in the backyard and a w without gates that go between all
the different lots,
uh,
and it would be quite normal for somebody to get in the car and the driver all
the way around the block to take their kids to somebody,
uh,
somebody else's house that might be,
less than a baseball throw away.
So that,
uh,
patterns of development,
encourage patterns of transit,
uh,
that,
have just an enormous influence on the way that we consume,
uh,
electricity,
but also petroleum products.
Uh,
so I think also about,
uh,
the cities in the nation that during the 1990s and,
and over the past decade of experience,
some of the rap,
most rapid rates of growth,
well,
these include Las Vegas in Las Vegas is expanding,
uh,
into the desert,
that,
uh,
in,
in a manner and at a density,
uh,
that,
is suburban.
It's sprawling,
but it's unusual in Las Vegas because of the environment.
So that a,
the every,
every house,
uh,
oh,
would,
would likely have a lawn.
The lawn would require a sprinkling.
Many of these houses also,
uh,
once they're,
they're built out,
I would have swimming pools,
uh,
so that,
think about the way that the use of water demands energy,
uh,
to not just move it around,
not just the distribution,
but also filtration.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
the energy that goes into putting in the infrastructure to move it around.
Now on Thursday,
and we're going to come back and talk more about,
uh,
the,
the new town movement in the United States and,
uh,
this problem of,
of managing growth at a larger scale than,
than today's lecture,
which is really focused on the building,
uh,
individual buildings.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it is interesting that a,
a movement evolved in the 1960s and 1970s in the United States to,
to design neighborhoods,
to design a whole new communities in a way that would take into account some of
these problems.
Uh,
Irvine,
California as the example in this slide.
And,
uh,
you can see the,
the center of the campus,
but you can also see,
uh,
the large academic buildings surrounding a green in the center.
And then the,
in the,
uh,
adjacent areas,
you have recreational facilities,
uh,
but also higher density housing nearby.
It's a very walkable community,
uh,
one that,
is not based on the idea of segregating land use is commercial versus
residential versus industrial versus recreational.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
in,
in suburban Connecticut,
uh,
you put your kids in a car and you drive from,
from the,
the area where you live,
to where you work,
uh,
to the recreational area,
to dance lessons,
whatever it is.
So the,
uh,
this community,
was intentionally designed back in the sixties and seventies,
uh,
in a way that would provide for mixed land uses and offer opportunities for,
much,
uh,
increased pedestrian traffic as opposed to a suburban areas around new haven.
Here's an example of a community about 20 miles away,
uh,
that,
many,
uh,
of my colleagues live in.
And,
uh,
this is a zoning at a scale of about a one unit per four to five acres.
So each of these houses,
uh,
has a strip of land that,
reaches back from it into an area that might otherwise be a common open space so
that,
uh,
this,
low density development demands even more time spent in cars in more fuel.
A good example of a house in a more rural part of Connecticut.
So that,
uh,
keep these things in mind as you're thinking about your own behavior,
the way you grew up,
uh,
and you try to consider how,
how your lifestyle choices,
uh,
influenced your family's consumption level.
Also,
a,
I want you to think about the idea of size and how we are increasingly dependent
upon many consumer products in our,
in our,
uh,
lives that are larger than they used to be.
Uh,
and,
uh,
housing is no,
no,
uh,
exception so that the average house size in 2009 is,
is grown to about 2,500 square feet,
uh,
with about 2.3 on average people per house.
That's really pretty remarkable.
So,
you know,
roughly a thousand square feet per person.
Whereas back in 1950,
the average number of people in a house was about,
uh,
much closer to three,
a little bit over three with a port post World War II,
baby boom,
uh,
with a total size of 800 square feet.
So the house size has grown by,
by a threefold 1970 grew to a 1500 feet.
So the energy demands of a larger house like that,
uh,
are,
are actually quite difficult to predict if you try to take into account,
uh,
the diversity of building materials.
Well,
I apologize for this and,
uh,
you know,
we,
one of you might go outside and let them know that there's a lecture going on in
here that would be a really nice,
the construction is,
um,
it's,
uh,
creating also a diesel fumes inside the,
the building.
Uh,
many of the garages that you find in suburban areas,
uh,
also have grown in size.
So here's an example of a garage that,
uh,
is actually larger than the average house size was back in 1950.
Uh,
this is probably about a 22,
23 by a 30 foot house.
So that's roughly 1200 square feet.
Pretty interesting.
I'm thinking about the way that,
uh,
space is laid out.
Uh,
so here's a studio apartment,
uh,
on the right hand side.
And,
uh,
you see a dining table,
a kitchenette walking closet in the bath on the,
on the upper level,
whereas the base level is,
is dominated by a garage so that,
uh,
we're,
we're allocating less space indoors to,
uh,
our bedrooms and we are to,
to,
uh,
our,
our auto storage areas.
Also,
many buildings are now constructed with much more glass in them than,
uh,
previously.
Uh,
and the newer high end buildings are using a special glass that is designed to
reflect radiation,
uh,
so that,
it's not absorbed,
uh,
but a different glasses are really designed for different climatic regions,
so that,
uh,
some are more,
more efficient at reflecting radiation,
uh,
that,
are used in southern climates that are warmer and others are more efficient,
uh,
at providing insulating a installation.
So they've got a barrier,
uh,
in the,
in the interior that,
uh,
basically protects against a heat loss.
Uh,
so that,
that,
uh,
overall though,
buildings,
uh,
increased use of,
of windows,
uh,
has,
created a increased energy demands.
Uh,
also lighting,
uh,
and also the way that we,
have,
uh,
increasingly designed bathrooms,
to have more than one fixed year.
Uh,
so here's an example of a shower stall that has,
uh,
a multiple shower heads in it,
multiple faucets,
uh,
so that,
water demand is,
is a often increased in,
uh,
bathrooms designed like this.
Uh,
most green building programs also attempt to regulate the building materials
that are used in furnishings.
So here's an example of a,
a bookcase,
uh,
and set of drawers seemingly are made out of Oak.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this is actually an,
an oak veneer.
Um,
and,
uh,
if you have been up in coon hall where the Forestry Environmental Studies,
school is,
you may know that,
uh,
about 70% of the wood that's on the interior of this was grown on yell property
on your forests.
Uh,
it also is,
is Red Oak,
but it's solid red oak.
It's not a veneer.
So what's beneath the veneer here you can see a strip of press board,
uh,
that,
is faced with,
with,
uh,
a white oak surface.
But the interior is,
is basically a low grade wood chips,
a of a variety of different species that are compressed together.
Uh,
and they are,
are mixed up in liquid form with adhesives.
Uh,
and then they are ruled out on a strip and then cut into a variety of different
sizes.
Uh,
the adhesives have compounds that,
uh,
are often proprietary and even unknown to most,
who purchased them at that,
uh,
or sell them a at building supply houses.
They commonly contain,
uh,
adhesives that are a poxy resins,
some of which contained Biz Faena lay that we talked about earlier in the
course.
Uh,
but also formaldehyde is a component that is commonly used.
It is an allergen and it's a,
uh,
a suspected carcinogen like you to think too about the problem of you're
understanding how,
how could you increase your understanding of the energy intensity of your own
lifestyle?
Well,
here's a,
a pretty good example of,
um,
the way that houses that were built in the 1990s and,
uh,
previously our metered,
so that this is what your,
your utility junction box,
where the line comes in from the road.
Uh,
this is my meter.
I have the same brand and it's got five dials on it.
And you might think,
well,
that's not that tough to figure out,
but if you walk up to it,
you'll see that the dial is actually have the numbers that,
uh,
on the first dial on the left,
it goes from lowest to highest in a clockwise motion.
But in the second,
it goes from lowest to highest and a counterclockwise motion.
So the,
they switch on as you move across the screen.
So this is actually a very difficult thing to keep track of.
Now also,
uh,
you might,
wonder,
well,
you know,
uh,
how would I find out,
you know,
how my variance in behavior,
uh,
you know,
how I manage my computers are my lights or my water consumption or how big a
refrigerator I,
I have,
how is that going to affect my electric bill?
It's really hard to figure it out,
given this kind of a metering system,
because if you can decipher what the,
the,
uh,
meter says,
you'll only get a total figure for your consumption.
Now,
this has created an opportunity for people to design a variety of smart meters,
uh,
that keep track of,
of energy intake and use and,
uh,
how it's distributed in a,
in a house for different purposes.
So that,
uh,
I tried to figure this out,
given my a dial meter at my home and ended up turning off absolutely everything
in the house and then starting up appliances one by one.
So I'd start the refrigerator,
then I turned the refrigerator off,
I'd start a drier,
uh,
start a dishwasher.
But,
uh,
that would be the only appliance that I would have running so that,
but you can imagine every time you plug in one and then,
uh,
go out to the meter and take a reading,
come back in,
uh,
unplug it and plug in something else.
It's going to take you a very long time to figure out where you're,
you're spending your money.
By doing that,
uh,
over a period of about eight hours,
I was able to save about 25% of my average monthly energy bill,
uh,
by,
by figuring out how to restrict access or fully,
fully turn off different appliances in the house,
a building products and building construction is,
uh,
normally regulated by a variety of building codes,
many of which had been adopted internationally so that these codes,
uh,
apply to materials.
Uh,
they apply to two electrical systems.
they apply to two energy sources,
fire prevention,
um,
mechanical heating and ventilation and air conditioning systems,
uh,
plumbing,
they even apply to historical sites,
uh,
in an earthquake prone parts of,
of,
uh,
the country.
Uh,
they,
uh,
have a code that is distinctive in California for earthquake stability,
so that these codes,
uh,
evolved,
originally as being voluntary so that they were not formally adopted by state or
local governments.
But now you find most states do have a similar kinds of building codes and they
were originally designed to promote,
uh,
understanding of,
of the functionality and the safety and the durability of different kinds of
products,
uh,
also to promote truth in labeling.
Uh,
but,
uh,
they,
they never really were designed to promote environmental responsibility,
health protection or a energy efficiency so that the green building movement was
really ripe for,
for a,
a,
a brand new certification system,
uh,
that,
would,
would apply a variety of different kinds of standards.
And,
uh,
the three programs that,
I'll mention today include the lead program by the US Green Building Council,
uh,
the bream program in the United Kingdom and the Green Star program in Australia.
Uh,
and the bre environmental assessment method is perhaps the best known,
uh,
in the world right now.
And it's the most widely adopted throughout Europe and a,
it sets standards for the back for best practices and sustainable design.
Uh,
and it's become really a,
a defacto measure used to describe a building's environmental performance.
Uh,
within the European Union.
Australia has,
uh,
the,
the Green Star program,
which is a national,
it's also voluntary,
uh,
that evaluates construction,
environmental design.
Uh,
and to has been,
uh,
particularly a well developed for commercial structures,
especially office buildings in downtown districts were about 11% of the
buildings have had been constructed and a certified under the program.
So it's purposes are to first of all,
try to figure out a common language and common definition for what mean is,
uh,
so that,
before the national organic food standard was adopted,
uh,
there was no national consistency in the definition of what organic food was.
Uh,
so it varied by a certification scheme.
It also,
uh,
the greenstar program also sets measurement standards.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
there is a common approach to,
to measuring,
uh,
say energy consumption or,
or,
uh,
the capacity of a different building materials such as electrical conduit.
Uh,
and they also promoted a,
uh,
a whole building design.
So that one would think about not just the individual components,
the individual building materials,
uh,
or the,
the different systems.
And by systems I mean like water supply,
electrical supply,
uh,
perhaps the heating and ventilation system or plumbing.
Uh,
but to figure out how to put all of these components together in a way,
uh,
that,
would,
would minimize,
uh,
the,
long term adverse effect on environmental quality or human health or energy
loss.
So this idea that a one would think about building materials in the,
in the style of,
of,
uh,
design,
in a way that we consider the ultimate product life cycle.
This is really a pretty new idea in the building industry,
so that,
uh,
you know,
what's going to happen to that PVC pipe that exists in your house when your
building gets torn down.
Uh,
what's going to happen to,
uh,
the,
the copper piping that delivers the water or the PVC pipe,
you can almost be assured is going to be either burned or it's going to be
discarded,
discarded in a landfill,
up with the copper piping is highly likely to be recycled because of its,
uh,
of its,
market value.
So differences in these programs are normally associated with the way that they
allocate credits or,
or points to buildings for different purposes.
Uh,
but,
uh,
there they really are quite similar and in their attempt to,
to,
uh,
promote energy conservation concern for chemical life cycles as well as human
health.
So the Green Building Council evolved in the beginning of 1993.
Uh,
and this is what I want to focus on now for,
for the remainder of the session.
And it is a voluntary nonprofit organization,
uh,
that has no government affiliation,
although it was started by a grant from the US Energy Department.
So,
uh,
this is,
created with a board of directors that include,
uh,
people that have expertise in architecture and engineering as well as some of
the largest,
uh,
development firms,
construction firms in the nation.
There are,
are really not,
uh,
a number of people on this board or on the staff that have a deep environmental
or health expertise,
uh,
and its orientation is predominantly been to promote energy efficiency.
They claimed that the benefits of this,
this,
uh,
leadership and energy and environmental design,
which is what the lead acronym stands for,
uh,
that there,
it has three predominant purposes.
One is to promote environmental quality.
The second is economic development to uh,
basically stimulate,
uh,
a,
a new type of building,
a new building materials that,
that are more environmentally responsible,
sorry about the noise and also to PR to promote a healthy
lifestyles within buildings and communities and by healthy lifestyles within a
building.
And I'll give you one example.
A colleague of mine works at the Centers for disease control in Atlanta and they
have a relatively new building and a just as a,
a healthy lifestyle.
Uh,
they,
uh,
attribute,
they decided that instead of putting a staircase in the back of the building and
the elevator right near the front door,
when people walked in that they would reverse that.
So the elevator was put in the back,
uh,
in the staircase,
was surrounded by glass panels,
uh,
that,
made it really light sunlight streams through and attractive so that people when
they go into the building,
normally walk up the stairs,
uh,
seven or eight story building.
So that this individual who directs or directed the National Center for
Environmental Health told me that he and his staff,
you know,
didn't,
nobody uses the elevator.
Everybody goes up and down the stairs.
So that Burns,
uh,
it saves energy or the elevator's not used much in,
in also it,
uh,
also is,
is a healthy,
it's burning a burning up calories.
So that a,
the purpose of lead falls into a variety of categories.
One is sustainable sites and other is water efficiency.
Another is energy and atmosphere.
Another is materials and resources.
Uh,
the fifth is indoor environmental quality.
And uh,
the fourth is really creativity and innovation and design.
So I mean you might imagine a different categories might be a part of,
of a system such as this.
Uh,
but uh,
there,
there are interesting questions about the relative importance that these
categories should be assigned.
Should you,
should you be assigned as much about the nature of the site that's chosen for
building a,
whether or not it's remote and a is going to be in a,
in a Greenfield area as opposed to the site that might be the,
uh,
hazardous and contaminated so that the coon hall up on,
on prospect street across from the whale coon hall was built on a highly
contaminated site,
uh,
so that a former power plant was there and a lot of work had to be done to,
to clean that site up to,
to remove contaminated debris as well as other infrastructure.
The,
uh,
the heating and electrical and,
and,
uh,
hot air conduits that,
go from the power plant up to science hill.
Particularly client science tower,
so that the idea that,
uh,
you would give more credits to,
a building program that,
uh,
would not chew up,
undisturbed areas that are in,
uh,
say,
the suburbs.
Uh,
you,
you'd give more credit to those that,
uh,
we're,
actively going to restore sites.
Is it an interesting concept?
[inaudible]
the certification program,
uh,
that I'm going to talk about today,
it has to do with,
with new construction and renovation,
although there are other programs that that lead has a,
for example,
a program for schools,
a program for,
for homes.
So that in this program there are a hundred base points plus a 10 possible bonus
points.
Uh,
and,
uh,
there are different,
levels of certification that can be achieved.
So if you achieve,
uh,
40,
42 or 49 points,
uh,
you are certified,
up to 50 to 59 points.
A,
you're given a silver certification,
a goal is 60 to 79,
and then platinum is 80 to 110 points.
Uh,
you can imagine a variety of different strategies here.
that,
uh,
I would hold the bar higher for,
for the base level of certification,
uh,
or perhaps,
hold the bar higher for only the platinum level.
The croon building was just certified to be a platinum building as,
as an example.
So,
uh,
these are the different kinds of certification programs that lead has beneath
its umbrella.
Uh,
and as I mentioned,
the first one,
new construction and renovation is the subject of today's talk,
uh,
but also schools,
core and Shell,
uh,
components of buildings on neighborhood development,
retail facilities,
healthcare facilities,
uh,
commercial interiors and homes.
Sorry,
I've got a couple of duplicate slides here.
So I'd like you to think about sustainable sites.
Uh,
credits that,
uh,
credits can be awarded a four,
building a previously developed land.
Uh,
they give additional credits for minimizing impacts on ecosystems and waterways,
uh,
for promoting a landscaping that is regionally appropriate.
Uh,
so if,
for example,
in the slide that I showed in Arizona,
uh,
if you were trying to get leed certification for a new project,
you would need to be very careful about the kind of landscaping that you put in
making certain that it wasn't a,
uh,
water dependent.
Uh,
the whether or not the building site encourages,
uh,
access to public transportation.
So proximity say to a rail station,
uh,
would,
include the number of points,
uh,
the control of storm water runoff and erosion.
So as an example,
there,
coon hall has a very large gutter that overhangs the south side and a funnel's
watered down into that,
a a watered garden that is on the eastern side of the,
uh,
of the structure.
And then that water moves through a filtration plant,
uh,
inside the building and then is recycled into two gray water so that it is used
for removal of human waste in the bathrooms.
Uh,
also here's an example of,
of how that building a,
achieve certain points by,
uh,
the restoration program,
digging out the old contaminated lands,
uh,
and,
rebuilding.
So four,
for each of these categories.
I'm not going to spend much time on this.
Uh,
but for each of the categories you can achieve points in different directions.
And you can imagine that the way that these points are allocated category by
category could have a,
a pretty significant implication for,
for,
uh,
providing encouragement.
By the way,
why would a developer want to be lead certified anyway?
You know,
what's the,
uh,
what's the value?
Well,
I mean,
I,
I mentioned one value,
uh,
that,
would be to the,
uh,
the building industry,
at large,
but,
uh,
which is,
the,
uh,
creating an incentive for,
for,
uh,
a new line of products and a new,
of,
uh,
approach to building design,
that,
uh,
would create a jobs and,
and,
uh,
cause the industry to grow.
Uh,
generally.
but,
uh,
most developers are in this because they know that if they achieve certification
than the property value is higher,
they can demand a premium,
uh,
for,
the,
uh,
the structure or the,
the complex.
So that,
uh,
in this case,
the sustainable sites category,
uh,
allows one to,
to,
uh,
seek about 23% of the total number of credits that are possible.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
these can be awarded for Brownfield redevelopment for alternative
transportation.
The,
uh,
the bike storage area that you find,
on,
uh,
behind,
Osborne Laboratory,
uh,
caused fes to gain additional points.
Uh,
the,
uh,
management of,
of,
uh,
storm water,
trying to,
uh,
manage,
a heat island effect,
reduce that,
uh,
intensity of heat absorption by creating green roofs.
Uh,
they also,
uh,
there was a green roof that's on part of that site.
Uh,
water efficiency also is a source of possible points,
about 9% of the total.
Uh,
and so that,
uh,
within this category,
appliance efficiency,
our fixtures and fittings are good examples of different ways of saving water,
uh,
as well as the landscaping that I mentioned earlier.
I wanted to mention a couple of,
uh,
kind of relatively recent technological designs.
Uh,
one is,
is,
uh,
these,
levelness faucets,
uh,
that,
since your,
your presence either by,
uh,
an electronic high or,
or,
uh,
sensing,
heat,
uh,
that causes them to turn on and off.
And it's,
it's kind of interesting.
You know,
I,
uh,
become,
curious more curious about this and watch people's,
uh,
hand washing behavior,
particularly in places like airports.
And it's really common to have a whole,
uh,
array of these things on a countertop.
Uh,
and people often have to move from one to the other to get one to work.
And after that happens,
a number of times,
people I think are more likely just to,
to not wash their hands.
So there's a sanitation problem that a is potentially associated with it.
If you go into the men's rooms a and look at the flush lists,
a urinals,
uh,
you will immediately recognize that there is a serious problem in [inaudible].
And it,
uh,
it's a,
led many due to argue that,
uh,
they really would rather make the trade off between the,
the,
the odor in the bathroom.
Uh,
uh,
and,
that might otherwise be managed by,
uh,
improving the heating and ventilation system so that,
right now,
uh,
no water is used in this toilet.
Uh,
only a synthetic compound is put in to try to maintain it's a sanitation,
but,
uh,
it often is not as effective as as it is promoted to be,
so that a water efficiency,
uh,
can be achieved in a variety of ways.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the faucets themselves are often fitted with the restrictions in a flow,
so that,
uh,
the,
the need to,
uh,
if you're,
if you're interested in,
uh,
taking a more powerful shower,
you'll need to figure out how to get the flow restrictor out.
Uh,
which many people do try,
do,
try.
The flow restrictor itself is governed by local and state building codes.
Uh,
and it was kind of interesting to me.
It was that an education for me,
uh,
when I wondered last a plumber who was installing a new faucet in my sink and I
said,
you know,
I really would like a larger rate of flow in this sink.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
you know,
I could be more effective in washing dishes or whatever.
And he said,
well,
you know,
uh,
you really don't understand the energy implications of,
of uh,
uh,
not restricting the flow.
And,
uh,
if,
if you thought about it,
then you'd realize that,
uh,
the energy costs are really quite high to move the water to your home.
I said,
well,
I've got my own.
Well,
he said,
well,
think about where,
uh,
where the energy is coming from,
that,
uh,
causes your pump to lift the water 600 feet.
And then also think about,
uh,
the more,
what are the CI use,
the more waste you create,
so you're likely to disperse a biological and chemical contaminants more
broadly.
So my plumber gave me a lesson in environmental behavior that I thought was
quite valuable.
So the majority,
not the majority,
but the highest proportion of points or credits are awarded under the lead
program,
uh,
for energy,
and atmospheric concerns,
uh,
so that,
new buildings can,
uh,
obtain points by,
by a monitoring energy consumption.
And this is being pretty carefully done.
And in coon hall as an example,
uh,
and the,
orientation of the building at Croon,
it's,
it's facing east to west,
uh,
so that,
it has,
uh,
more window space on the south side to absorb more solar radiation,
radiation.
It also has solar panels that run a clock across the south side,
uh,
and,
a variety of other,
uh,
saving,
techniques so that,
uh,
the dominance of,
of energy and energy conservation in,
in,
uh,
the Leed certification and credit program relative to these other categories is,
quite interesting,
uh,
with respect to materials and resources.
Uh,
the,
uh,
management of waste is also a more intensely monitored,
within a leed certified building.
Uh,
and,
uh,
when a building is actually certified,
it's not certified for forever.
It's certified for a fixed period of time,
um,
often only a single year.
And a building is not certified until it can demonstrate that a,
it is performed at a level of ex,
uh,
during that year.
So it's kind of an interesting idea.
Uh,
if,
uh,
buildings,
heating and ventilation system malfunctions,
uh,
then,
a year or two down the road,
it's not going to be recertified.
Uh,
indoor environmental quality,
uh,
is,
increasingly a concern and only 15 points compared to about 34 points in the
energy category.
Only 15 points are allocated for indoor environmental quality.
Now what does,
what does,
uh,
what does that mean?
It generally means a concern for,
for,
uh,
the chemical content of the indoor environment.
Uh,
but it also includes the opportunity to,
to gain points for a natural daylight and views and also for,
uh,
a acoustical control noise control.
Um,
so that,
uh,
the situation that we're experiencing here might be avoided.
Now,
you know,
uh,
again,
think about the importance of this in terms of a human chemical exposure,
uh,
given the fact that we spend so much time indoors.
You know,
this diagram is now a couple of years old.
Uh,
but,
uh,
in the,
latter part of,
of,
uh,
the 1990s was estimating that about 86,
87% of time was spent indoors,
about 5% of time was spent in a vehicle.
So thinking about the chemical content of the indoor environment is important,
especially for certain subgroups like kids.
Uh,
this can be managed in a variety of ways.
And you could,
you could think,
well,
the,
the ventilation rate or the air exchange rate indoor and outdoors is one way of
doing that depending upon where your building is.
Uh,
so in general,
outdoor air quality is better than indoor air quality,
you know,
unless you live in proximity to an industrial area or,
or,
uh,
to a highway.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
being able to mechanically and individually control,
windows is an important strategy for,
for managing air quality,
but also thinking about a variety of different,
uh,
materials and compounds that are brought into the built environment so that some
compounds are,
and some products are discouraged under this program.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
paints for example,
that emit a high level of volatile organic compounds are discouraged.
So low emitting,
uh,
paints a varnishes polyurethanes are now designated,
so that,
uh,
if,
if you look at the cannabis oil based paint,
you'll find that that uh,
roughly two and a half pounds of volatile organic compounds are contained,
whereas,
uh,
a certain paints are now manufactured with no volatile organic compounds.
You might also think about the compact fluorescence that pose a kind of an
interesting problem,
uh,
in that,
they contain mercury.
Uh,
and so that,
uh,
this is,
a piece of personal advice for you.
Uh,
as you install or remove compact fluorescents,
be really careful about them because if the break in your room,
it's gonna scatter mercury around and the Mercury will vaporize.
Uh,
if it gets into a rug and you vacuum the rug,
the rug is going to do,
uh,
give off the mercury vapors and it will increase the validation rate.
Uh,
and it will be just about impossible to completely remove the mercury from the
room.
So this is a,
this is a problem associated with a compact fluorescence,
uh,
that,
is turning into a,
a,
a rather interesting and a serious dilemma for,
for a waste management.
So not many people really want to take a,
an old burned out,
a light pole back to,
to a recycling center.
Uh,
in fact,
uh,
the probability of getting it there without breaking it is,
is,
uh,
probably not too great.
And also think about,
uh,
again,
plastics and landfill and increasing proportion of the interior built
environment is made up of a variety of plastics at we've talked about in the
past.
Uh,
but the,
the extremely low chance that plastics are going to be a recycled,
uh,
is,
a logic to,
to rethink the way that points are allocated.
A,
there was an interesting debate inside the Green Building Council about a
polyvinyl chloride plastics.
And whether or not the PVCs ought to be,
uh,
either band,
or whether or not you would have credits removed if you use PVC as opposed to a
more recyclable product like polyethylene,
uh,
that,
you know,
the most soda bottles are made out of a,
but they decided not to do that,
which is quite curious.
Uh,
so thinking about,
uh,
the kinds of materials that are put down on a floors,
the,
the sealants also,
this is a encouraged credits can be gained if you choose a,
not just the low voc paints,
but also the clear finishes.
Also,
you'll find a variety of products including this type of a vinyl flooring,
uh,
that you could see in coon hall,
particularly in the stairwells,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
gives off a volatile compounds that,
that,
uh,
I haven't been able to identify and,
and the manufacturers are not required two to label.
So thank you.
Think about the variety of different,
uh,
products that go into purchasing a or go go into the construction of a building.
And how these products may change the chemical content of,
of that environment.
So that,
uh,
the,
the quality of the air exchange system is,
is really critical,
uh,
to,
to govern the,
the,
uh,
chemical exposures that occur.
And this is particularly the case in a new building.
Uh,
as an example,
a rugs,
rugs maybe made out of a natural products,
natural fibers,
uh,
such as a wool or cotton or,
or,
uh,
some,
now it's increasingly some,
um,
uh,
read material from,
South America,
but,
uh,
rugs that are made out of synthetic compounds and they're backing,
many are recommending that those be aired out in a warehouse or,
or,
uh,
in a garage for a period of time,
you know,
up to a couple of weeks before they're installed so that,
uh,
I,
occupants of new buildings would not be exposed to those fumes.
A couple of other examples that are not managed by lead a certain golf courses
have been been a certified.
Uh,
whereas,
uh,
the expectation on the part of the Green Building Council is that the chemicals
that are used are regulated by the Environmental Protection Agency.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the chemicals that are used on golf courses are commonly,
quite a,
uh,
a complex mixture.
Uh,
and,
uh,
as you remember from the pesticide section of the course of many of these have
not been fully tested.
A variety of insulating materials also,
uh,
can expose workers,
at levels that are potentially hazardous to their health.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
some,
acrylics,
uh,
for example,
that,
uh,
play an important role in increasing the,
the,
uh,
energy efficiency,
the building,
uh,
but they can lead to a worker exposure situations.
So thinking about,
uh,
whether or not lead should get involved in,
in,
uh,
concern about,
the production of the chemical and its application and the way that it's
actually used it to build the building is interesting.
Lead is also certified,
uh,
a bottling plant raising kind of an interesting question.
Well,
what if a,
say a dupont corporation,
uh,
wanted to build a plant to produce a variety of chemicals that were extremely
hazardous and perhaps they,
uh,
they got into water or air,
soil,
uh,
should they be allowed to get a platinum or a lead certification for,
for that structure shouldn't necessarily be allowed to,
to,
uh,
gain certification,
for,
uh,
marketing,
products that,
uh,
are not likely to be recycled.
Ah,
here's another example of a,
uh,
a project that was certified in,
in Florida a and you remember the lecture last week about a barrier islands.
Uh,
well,
this owner a,
owns the track of land,
uh,
slicing across a barrier island from the bay to the shoreline.
Uh,
and obviously has quite intensively developed it.
You know,
seeing the amount of square footage,
uh,
in,
in homes and the low occupancy rates,
uh,
is,
led me to wonder about whether or not government might think about regulating a
square foot per person or a cubic foot per person.
Uh,
I mean,
how much space do we really need per person?
So I'm going to run through just a few summary of,
of findings here before I close today.
Uh,
that should give you a sense of,
of,
uh,
you know,
what's working and what's not working too well with the lead program.
These standards have been designed by,
uh,
a voluntary nonprofit organization,
but they've been adopted increasingly at all levels of government,
uh,
in law.
So they've been added to a Connecticut's laws for,
for example,
to the Connecticut now requires that new buildings,
uh,
that,
are going to cost more than $5 million,
need Leed Leed certification.
Uh,
many of the Department of Energy's programs are now designed to encourage,
uh,
giving of grants to two projects that,
gain lead certification or would gain lean leed certification and meet many
local governments are now adopting these standards so that,
uh,
well what's happening here is that the standards are being developed by a
voluntary,
a nonprofit organization really to promote a new form of,
of growth and development.
Uh,
but they're being incorporated wholesale into a variety of different levels of
government,
uh,
without really thinking critically about what's working well.
And what's not a,
there's no now no federal definition of what a green building standard,
uh,
should be.
Uh,
clearly this program gives a higher priority to energy efficiency over a indoor
environmental quality or,
or human health.
Uh,
and,
uh,
if I were going to design a,
a statute that,
uh,
would encourage green building,
it would certainly give increased precedence,
uh,
to,
to public health concerns and,
and,
uh,
the chemical content of buildings.
Uh,
the Green Building Council has very little expertise in,
in a human health and that in part explains why these standards are,
are uh,
uh,
not well developed in that area.
Still the green certification program,
the lead program,
uh,
it gives a false impression of,
of healthy buildings and tighter buildings are,
are more energy efficient,
but tighter buildings also more effectively contain chemicals that get into
indoor air so that,
uh,
no level of certification,
even the highest level.
The platinum rating assures health protection.
I'll lead,
also neglects drinking water,
uh,
so that,
drinking water supplies,
uh,
are managed in,
in the nation predominantly by the safe drinking water act.
And the maximum contaminant level standards.
So there is no requirement under lead to certify,
uh,
two,
excuse me,
to a,
to filter water
despite the fact that,
uh,
many waterlines are capable of transmitting,
not just metals,
but also,
uh,
some of the components of plastics.
So that the,
uh,
the core problem with respect to managing,
chemicals,
uh,
in the indoor environment and the ultimate life cycle cycle of chemicals I has
to do with,
uh,
congresses,
inactivity.
It's failure to demand that the chemicals that are used in the building
industry,
uh,
be labeled a,
that they be tested before they're used.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
it's creating a pattern of exposure that a really,
we don't understand.
Well,
we know we're being exposed,
uh,
to a,
a brand new mixture of compounds.
So what kinds of recommendations might you think about to improve this system?
Well,
one would be to simplify the scoring system so that,
uh,
the,
rather than using the,
uh,
the platinum,
the gold standards,
I would prefer to see a scale that was simply a zero to a 100 scale.
So that people would,
would,
uh,
not have the incentive just to get to 80 points so that,
that,
uh,
would ensure that they would be awarded that the,
the platinum certification,
I think that,
uh,
the,
the categories of certification,
uh,
need to be diversified.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
if the Green Building Council judged and scored a project's performance and
separate categories,
uh,
developers would have an incentive to score a higher in all those categories.
In other words,
set up a separate a scoring system for indoor environmental quality and human
health set up,
set up a separate system for energy efficiency,
set up a separate system for,
for water supply.
Uh,
but whether or not we want to have this system managed by,
uh,
a nonprofit organization that is run by the board of directors,
that to have predominantly for profit organizations.
Uh,
that's another basic question.
So should the federal government take this over?
So this system is not designed in its current form to encourage the use of
safety,
safer chemicals in the building industry,
so that,
uh,
what kinds of innovations might encourage a builders to,
want to buy buildings or buy a building products that contain safer products.
While they would certainly need to know what the chemicals a war in the product,
so that a,
there's a labeling issue that needs to be confronted,
but also there's a testing issue,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
the Green Building Council also has the opportunity not to disclose,
uh,
the results of,
of it's a building performance tests so that the public really has a,
excuse me.
The public has no,
uh,
opportunity to,
to,
uh,
hold,
the Green Building Council accountable for its declaration of a performance in
different categories.
So I think I'll close with a thought that,
uh,
this is a very interesting historical example of how,
certification standards evolved in a nonprofit organization that really is
representing a for profit industries.
The,
the large,
uh,
building products industry,
the major building companies,
large architectural firms and engineering firms.
Uh,
and this program has no accountability at all to the United States public,
uh,
at the same time that it's being built into law at all levels of government.
So something seems really,
uh,
very much out of whack a and a,
it demands,
I think,
a,
a pretty careful review.
One critical,
uh,
improvement could be made if minimum performance criteria were set within each
of the specified categories,
sustainable sites,
energy,
uh,
the,
the category for indoor environmental quality,
so that if there were minimum,
uh,
and protective,
standard set inside those categories,
it would go a long way to meeting some of the objections I just raised.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
We'll come back to a larger questions of community design on Thursday.